should we get in some cats rap battle oh
it's back mm-hmm that was weeks ago
weeks ago weeks ago they tried it we Co
they tried it he goes this is like she's
yeah she just mmm yes I read for me both
speaking out before we get into
contenders we thought we had our first
female rapper she sent this in on
Twitter and let's give it a listen and
we're here with Michelle Mena spoken
word poet and what are you gonna do for
us today
I'm Michelle all right well let me sit
back then go ahead Michelle
[Laughter]
you want to just read something from
your book well so last week we had Don
verse papa bear and in the first round
Don beat Papa Bear like 77238 old and
then little brows retained his crown
against Don seventy-one to 29% so I walk
out the little brows in the crowd oh wow
girls gone wild been a bit with all
dudes yeah dudes gone wild that little
browse this dude's got wall to my crown
dude it's fantastic that's beautiful man
it's nice to see a bunch of young men
enjoying themselves yeah positive
attitudes shirts off
what's this so we got two new contenders
this week two-faced little brows and the
videos just keep getting more and more
produced this first one is from a rock
AR a a ra ra d is his name and his
artist name is a hice a hy es and this
is dedicated one of the greatest human
beings and souls I've ever known my
biggest supporter my best friend Ryan
Charlie r.i.p that's what it says
ah yes okay
can't get a stay and game bus shoutouts
to make right there in that guy's yard
Elaine much love to the king of the
sting the Rat King gets the King gonna
stink the Kings stink
Brendan you look like the king of the
twins i shoutouts to see chicas thinking
is not really his empty cast the
invincible drinks Theo looks like the
type of guy to wash his dick in the sink
I'm joking y'all killing it from the
jump my niece and nephew love you so go
ahead and pump this funk
many podcasts out there but what defines
is talent that's the higher than Derek
high advantage job and laughing he's
like an average medians like that birds
up in D'Elia the X fighter guy in the
child of Bryan Callen Oh everywhere a
mime an ex-fighter Brennan shop [ __ ] man
I apologize let me switch it up y'all
need to fly me out they say
to go on a date with cash
[Music]
without your problems and relief with
that go home and magically I'm just
joking my bad
I'm not joking either
[Music]
buzz-buzz gaining the spa
buzz
Ganga
[Music]
[Music]
love it those dopes Angra was really
dope
ah yes music Mikey bingo beats that was
fun it was good man that's a good vibe I
was fun for sure yeah definitely
definitely different than the rest it's
a good vibe yeah no way to put the top
down at the tip though yeah definitely
like that beat that it kind of has that
Moroccan zombie-like I could rock to
that Moroccan I said man pop a couple of
Coronas get jean shorts out rollerblades
Mike sorry yeah a couple my cards maybe
a Zima every now and then
oh I think you said Mike's hard all
that's our next rapper we got no this oh
this is Johnny C Oh Johnny C boy oh yes
from Georgia let me show you what a real
web sounds like just so you know I have
some contacts - it's the king of the
sting which a problem the be thickness
and sickness by shop CBT or Theo's
tattoo answers an ecstasy slip the
rodents a few now shows on cable mean
deal check them sell for pornography
I swear I got cat if I don't see your
feet I'm crashing into winning Backman
and New Orleans getting game buzz buzz
sting sting cook to push the back strap
another for you bring chance partying
again and it takes it to the big brown
bagging bails already has taken still a
lil brown kid a wax Oh be the
supervillain I was born in the doctor's
yellow faking it I stay on the wrong
rules you just do the same I gave you a
lame now stay in it before a call and
the kids talk used to be a game roasted
host drop knots
bustin ox and clowning cars getting gay
buzz buzz Gang Gang
no I said the rap king is beasting my
gangs buzz is no hey [ __ ] whoa want
some whiskey that Chappelle teeth gave
to wow man
dude he went and that was real it was
probably more or less produced maybe I
don't know was it I don't know any
problems like this well now the brows
can bring up that monster lebra's oh
shoot something uh whoever shoots
something up wins it go sign there yeah
okay dude we're not doing that on this
episode also that guy was pretty
gangster they're both good man yeah both
really good you try and see who's gonna
be little brows mm-hmm it's just a
different vibe like a little brows is on
that [ __ ] how many straight has a hit
on 105 nine well I yes music - the first
guy the first guy his was a hit -
different though there's more of a
beachy hit somebody's getting married at
the beach or somebody this bored
yeah he also did sing yeah I did you hit
that Drake on it yeah he had a little
more Drake on it I didn't some of the
verses I didn't get that much but it was
good though but it was cool he went
after cat hard he left a cat hard any
interest on that man yeah too big
I am very I don't like the attention
it makes me blush uncomfortable well
he's very nice though
that's very he looks like the it looks
like the bad guy and like in the goofy
cartoons the big guy
you don't talking about yeah don't act
out the real big one
it looks like Kelvin Gastelum if he
never fought and just hung out a
beautiful wild fare he looks like Aaron
Donald for the Aaron Donald for the Rams
yeah looks like your dog for the radio
this guy you mean no no no the other
disc Alex again no no no no the big guy
looks like you know Donald you know he's
a identical if Arab Donald was in a
[ __ ] we hope gay parade yeah yep the
jean jacket all low again that's all
yeah yeah that's him wrapping a cat
right there look man look I think browse
has both these guys they look identical
you know God's sakes
oh that's not a bag oh man you're right
come on son I think Brett I mean I don't
know I'll put it up to the people but on
my end what do we do cuz I don't know
yeah he looks identical that oh yeah
references to them it's good yeah I
represent on point today I don't know
what we do cuz I don't know if anybody's
can beat little brows he's that good is
he done fans luck well he's destroying
everybody but somebody's got to come at
him brah no one no one's come close the
last one was dawn I thought dawn would
get close Don said he has a remix that
he wants to send in so maybe next one
time we do it if little Brow's wins
again we can put them up against each
other a little rematch okay alright so
do we have a contender from today wins
browser no I'll go around the room okay
hmm chin contender today against to go
get across I like the rawness of the
last guy he's very raw he was on like
right there yeah but I don't think they
yeah I think they could compete what
Browse yeah I'm gonna go with that
second guy even though he's extremely
aggressive he had really good lyrics
although it's kind of cheating to just
use our segment titles to rhyme cuz they
all rhyme anyways but he was still
better yeah we kind of did the rhyming
for you
yeah pre rhyming I think I'm gonna go
with the second guy I like his
aggression I like the aggression on the
first guy I like the the flavor the
first guy what did you say I liked so
the second guy had better rhymes but the
the the the first guy is more fun in
word again joking man look I've said I
know how it feels and people you say
it's not cool man
people thought Don last he said Nixa gee
everybody thought he was saying n-word
but he didn't oh if he's straight I
would have called it we do have a good
that's a good point
I'm staying that look brows is still it
I these guys are thank you very much for
the submission they're great
yeah they're great I don't know who's
gonna come along be brows but I thought
that dominican guy went straight at
brows though I think we do what we did
last week we put those guys up against
each other in a vote and then the winner
faces a mile so yeah yeah then they can
get crushed by little brows it's a mile
around
[Music]
King
[Music]